and we start right here in germany where
it is looking increasingly likely that
angela merkel's conservators
conservatives will not be part of the
next government just over a week on from
the election both the green party and
the free democrats also known as fdp say
they will now seek further concrete
talks with the election winners the
social democrats and the hope of
delivering a governing coalition for
germany as soon as possible
after a first round of exploratory talks
in which parties got together for
bilateral meetings it was the greens who
came out with an opening gambit
announcing that they were keen to take
negotiations to the next level
after these initial talks we deliberated
and with a view to the common ground
that we managed to find in our bilateral
meetings we have come to the conclusion
that it now makes sense to deepen our
conversation with the fdp and the sbd
and that is what we will now propose to
the fdp
for all three parties to get together
and talk fdp
the leader of the business friendly fdp
promptly agreed
we have accepted the offer of further
talks with the spd to sound out common
ground that will push our country
forward
and the chancellor candidate for the
social democrats was confident that the
three parties could stand for that
change
the citizens of this country have given
us a mandate to form a government
together the most recent polls indicate
again and again that this is the will of
the people it's now on us to put this
into practice
it's about building a government that
will enact change and the necessary
modernization in germany
for the conservatives of outgoing
chancellor angela merkel this could
spell the end of their 16 years in
government
led by candidate armin lashed they came
second to the social democrats and
suffered their worst ever election
result but german coalition negotiations
are notoriously fragile
after the last election initial talks
collapsed and negotiations ended up
taking months
with that to happen again the
conservatives have already indicated
that they will be waiting in the wings
ready to pick up talks again
let's get you some background now dw
political correspondents julia saudelli
is standing by in our parliamentary
studio good to see you julia so what do
these developments suggest to you
well this means there is going to be
further talking it's uh just the initial
phase of the coalition building we've
seen these uh initial talks bilateral
talks between the different parties now
the parties are together going to enter
new exploratory talks talks that are
meant to define the broad a common
ground that they can agree on they're
going to try to build political
consensus and once they know that they
have a foundation on which to build a
coalition they will go into more
detailed coalition talks where they will
then deal with the nitty-gritty try to
find agreement on policies on new laws
that they want to enact on reforms that
they want to put forward but it will
entail a lot of compromise a lot of
willingness to negotiate but the three
parties seem confident that they will be
able to push that through and julia what
are some of the potential stumbling
blocks standing in the way of these
three parties reaching common ground
so we've seen the greens and the social
democrats already before the election
saying that they would be glad to govern
together and they are the two parties
that have the most things in common the
most policy points in common so the free
democrats the business friendly fdp are
a bit of the outlier here for example on
tax policy they do not want to raise
taxes for anyone in germany while the
two other parties were seeing in the
campaign that they wanted to increase
taxes on the richer part of the
population in term in terms of public
spending the fdp absolutely does not
want to increase public spending and
especially incurring
debt to finance of the public spending
the other two parties are more flexible
on wanting to maybe increase the debt
rate that germany can incur
for
investment but
the greens could also pose an issue
because they are the
most
active and they want to push the more
far-reaching policy to fight climate
change and they will have to try to
convince the other two parties to
follow their lead on climate change so
there is a lot of
need to find compromise and agreement
between the three parties
and julia what do these talks now mean
for angela merkel's cdu csu block
well at the moment it looks like the
conservatives have been sidelined in the
coalition talks and it is now looking
quite unlikely that they will end up in
government this time
we've uh however heard the greens and
the ftp say that they are not completely
closing the door on the conservatives
they said they are still willing to talk
to them
in the future if these coalition talks
were not to be successful with the
social democrats and amin lascit the
chancellor candidate for the
conservatives has said he is still open
to talks with them in the future but at
the moment they're going to have to wait
on the sidelines and hope that these
coalition talks don't go forward
otherwise they are likely to be out of
the german government dw political
correspondent julia saudelli reporting
thank you very much
you